cancel culture rearing its ugly head
again but thankfully more people are
fighting back this time the latest
example the White House attempting to
cancel the Atlanta Braves on the same
day that President Biden hosted them at
the White House to celebrate their World
Series championship
critics say the name of the team is
racist and offensive to Native Americans
and the liberal mob has been demanding
that they change it here's the White
House
we believe that it's important um
to have this conversation uh you know
and and Native American and Indigenous
voices they should be at the center of
this conversation that is something that
the president believes as something that
this Administration believes cancel
culture not new and legendary TV
personality Sharon Osbourne knows a
thing or two about it she's taking the
fight to the liberal mob and her new
four-part series Sharon Osbourne to Hell
and Back available now on Fox Nation it
documents the cancel culture Firestorm
that led to her departure from CBS
opinion show The Talk Osborne was
accused of being racist because she
defended her friend here's Morgan's
public criticism of Meghan Markle and
was later ambushed on the show take a
look
I was the the slam that was slaughtered
that morning and CBS denied the
responsibility on the news and that's
because
you can get ganged up on on live
television and when you go to defend
yourself against accusations you get
fired for creating a hostile work
environment
this is the world we live in today
Sharon welcome to the five thank you is
that still kind of upsetting to you when
you watch that what happened
um not anymore because I had eight
months of therapy so I think
did you like to use Cobra and extend
your uh health care or no you had to pay
off out of your pocket it's so wrong
what was that like for people you worked
with Executives you knew really kind of
stabbed you in the back and kind of set
you up how'd that make you feel
um Angry I was pissed off and angry and
at the same time hurt with my co-host
because especially one of the ladies I
thought was a friend of mine I sat next
to her for ten and a half years and I
thought she was my friend
you know the amazing part of it is that
you are in the crosshairs at CBS when
um it wasn't your fight you were simply
saying that Piers Morgan had the right
to express his opinion yeah and then all
of a sudden you were called out because
they said he was a racist but then I
said
where what is he written what has he
ever said that's racist and they
couldn't come up with anything and their
excuse was because Meghan Markle was a
woman of color he must be a racist to
say she was lying only a racist would do
that
and what about the underlying issue that
he says she was lying about what was it
that she was married before it was 17
comments that she made that were all
proven true later and
um so it was I'm prick I was sticking up
for my friend who is a journalist he has
freedom of speech as we all do and to
criticize somebody
fine you're you're entitled to do that
but because she was a lady of color then
that makes you racist I think you're the
only one that's ever stuck up for Piers
Morgan congratulations I I was wondering
if if going looking back if in the first
24 hours or even in your initial
feelings or response if you had to do it
over again if you had to go through it
again would you
react differently we do have advice for
people who are worried that this might
happen to them yeah I would have
absolutely and Jesse I'm speaking about
him
happy the notes okay number one I would
have looked into the camera and I would
have said this was never rehearsed this
was not the show I was told I was going
to do this morning you are setting me up
and I'm now leaving
but my head was I I was in like what's
going on here what's going on and I was
in I was shocked and then the more you
try and defend yourself the worse you
look
it would be like if Ansley induce you
just sandbagged you one morning which is
called Wednesday
Sharon here's the thing do you believe
it's pretty have you done any
investigating to see if it came from
management because obviously you think
it was orchestrated and they wanted to
get you out you were invaluable to the
show anyone who watched the show you
were the hinge of the show so that was
going to hurt the show to get you out
but it was important to get you out how
do you how do both worlds meet well I
was told by our show Runners this the
show was run by two ladies and I was
told by both of them that that morning
the woman who runs programming she runs
daytime and evening program at CBS told
them to do this to me
wow
so I mean have you thought about taking
action against them or just forget
obviously you turn the page you're
better off do you know you know what the
situation is do I want to spend two or
three years of my life fighting this
because you know judge that's how long
it would have taken do I want to lay out
the expense
no and that's why I did this documentary
and I I did it too because I didn't want
it to be the end of my career because
how dare they tell me when it's the end
of my career and that's what they
basically did in this country you have
very close family members and I'm
curious if you have thoughts about
if this is going to happen to somebody
like Jesse
um
but I I just wonder if there's a way for
family members to support somebody who
is going through this
um who any even if it's not public like
this it could just be in a small town
and it happens to somebody and their
loved ones don't know how to react or
how to support them was there something
that happened in your family that helped
you get through it love they would
support me they would tell me that you
know
this will pass you better than them
you're a genuine friend to people
they're not genuine and constantly my
family were telling me that and they
were saying you have a home to come back
to every night where you're loved most
of the people on that panel don't yeah I
have a feeling if I got canceled my mom
would say you know what Jessica
I wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now